tyloo and chauncy phillips somebody who
you know very well
you covered him
uh rookie here
head coach and lead assistant
for your
los angeles clippers
look the clippers
rightfully so once again the butt of
many a joke
uh fire doc rivers but
i like it i like it how you feel about
it and should clippers fans be excited
because they're still the clippers and
there's still a lot of questions about
the makeup of that team and it's not a
dramatic departure what one wouldn't
think because while ty lue is his own
coach and certainly had success in
cleveland um he was he was an assistant
on this very team that collapsed so how
do you feel about it but more important
michael how should clippers fans feel
about it well it's a good question mike
first of all as you mentioned off the
top
i'm happy for chauncey billup's lead
assistant
he came into the league after his
sophomore year in colorado
uh
joined rick pitino's boston celtics so
was rick pitino's first draft pick they
thought they would get tim duncan
they wound up with with chauncey
phillips so chauncey bill and ron mercer
right
yeah yes yeah i remember that and uh
let's listen phillips from the start i
can say this uh it's on record i wrote
this uh as early as 1997 i was saying
that phillips even a 20 years old
very wise uh wise cat
just had his uh just had a way about him
and even then everybody respects him
yeah he had to bounce around a little
bit before he found himself and i'm glad
he found himself as a player finals mvp
and o4 and then uh was a great uh
commentator i think he's going to do a
great job as a head coach and ty lue as
you know might look championship coach
so it's not like they got some scrub but
this is what i'm concerned about for the
clippers
ty lue was on doc rivers and staff in
boston
clearly on the staff again with the
clippers
according to reports mike
doc rivers told steve ballmer the owner
hey this is what we need what we need is
a change in attitude what we need is a
little more professionalism i guess
whatever whatever he said
and steve ballmer didn't like that
answer
and goes to ty lue but tyler was a part
of that same staff
yeah so like what what what do you what
do you think is going to change oh you
think they needed a different voice he
didn't like the message
so maybe it was the right message from
doc but he didn't like the messenger
or maybe it was just like the totality
of hey i'm still mad that you guys lost
to oklahoma city when you're up three
games to one i'm still mad at that so
this is not really about the bubble and
the collapse against the nuggets this is
about old stuff maybe i don't know it
just seems like a cosmetic change
so all right a couple of things i said i
liked it let me kind of rattle off the
reasons why
one
we got another black coach
let's put let's get that out there you
know what i mean there's a vacancy and i
know tyler's name was was was always a
favorite but we got another black coach
in the nba uh and
chauncey phillips uh gets an opportunity
as a lead assistant all right so that's
progress on that front so that's one
two um
in a vacuum if somebody were hiring ty
lue given his credentials
you'd say it's a good hire so yeah
because he was in a mix in houston and
maybe some other places it's a good hire
so i think it's a good hire it's good to
see him get another opportunity um three
and this is why i asked the question to
you the way i did it is it feels like
there's some continuity here and the
wrong kind of continuity if the if the
the goal was to kind of shake things up
a little bit but i wonder and i think
what it says though and you and i both
said this i mean doc only coach ever to
blow 331 leads
uh you know
there's
there's a lot of blame
to be placed at his feet for what
happened this year against denver
however i think you and i both knew
that doc alone wasn't the problem and
there were a lot of mitigating and
insinuating circumstances whether it was
the lack of chemistry that this team had
this year uh you know guys going in and
out of the bubble for various personal
reasons the collapse of a playoff p of
paul george uh you know there's a lot of
reasons why this team lost to a very
good denver team
um and so i think what it says more than
anything
is that
uh there was something fluky even though
we're talking about the clippers there
was something fluky about last year and
it was not necessarily an indictment of
the organization's direction in its
entirety i say i like to say michael i
look at this next season and i feel like
i am charlie brown if i'm a clipper i'm
acting like a clippers fan right now i
feel like i'm charlie brown and the
clippers are lucy and and the football
that is
you know the conference finals they're
about to yank it from me again because
i'm talking up the clippers and we've
seen how any movie regardless of this of
the characters and the supporting actors
and the plot line we've seen how any and
every movie when it comes to the los
angeles clippers ends we've seen it
however
you're telling me you're running back a
squad
with kawhi leonard
paul george paul george who
can't be
listen even if he's just relegated to
all-star you know versus the stone star
superstar
yeah stocks now get that but
she you gotta think that this team you
gotta think that this team
will
i i don't wanna just i don't wanna say
rally that's lazy but realize what an
opportunity it has in front of them
because if you pointed out from the
beginning they got one year to get this
thing done tyler's got a five-year
contract they got one year to get this
thing done with this group you got to
think that they'll that they can build
if if they are if they have if they have
anything inside of them but this team
has anything inside of him whatsoever
okay
they will take what happened this year
and use it to fuel them next year
they'll take watching the lakers hoist
another banner or or claim another larry
o'brien and fuel him going into next
year so i'm optimistic about it even
though we're talking about the clippers
you know what i mean man you know what
you just said something here it always
yeah because i said a lot and at one
point i was like am i making any sense
but go what do i do
no no no it got me it got me well a
couple things you talk about you know i
feel like uh
it was it was really fluky last year a
little bit of a fluke
something i don't want disrespect to
nuggets all with respect to nuggets but
yeah yeah but i can hear o'shea jackson
saying
anyone no fluke
i can just hear his voice o'shea jackson
are just having a good time with this
but the other thing is mike it just
it just strikes me that this is a good
job that's going to become a horrible
job in a year like you can see it coming
so he gets his five year contract
and
coaching being what it is in the nba
uh he's not going to get through the
five year contract because think about
it like look
unless
kawhi stays and paul george stays you've
got one year and he's done it before
under pressure that's how he won his
first championship david blatt out ty
lue in he gets him
in short time we'll talk about windows
winning with lebron is
is every year is a championship on
business lebron so he'll start with a
championship at that in a historic
championship so he can win quickly but
just think about it after this year
and those guys bounce
you don't have them nor do you have
picks
so you're stuck no kawhi leonard
no paul george no pick okay so you gotta
but you gotta act fast but you got an
owner you got an owner unlike one we're
gonna get to in a second down in houston
you got an owner that you know is gonna
spend that you know is gonna spare no
expense when it comes to putting this
team in position to succeed
well you got a lot of money so i i mean
i get i get maybe not draft capital and
this that they got a lot of money okay
post game spread
listen michael
michael you are talking to the person
you know this
when they was when they were playing the
nuggets we are switching rolls right
here we're switching roles in real time
when they were playing the nuggets i'm
like do not fall for this banana in the
tailpipe again these are the clippers
we're talking about they are coming
apart before our very eyes the nuggets
are going to do this you were like no
they're the better team and a better
team so let's let's just wipe the slate
clean we're on the next year you're
telling me going into next year going
into next year you don't like a team
led by ty lue and chauncey phillips with
kawhi leonard paul george
pat bev
montrez harold i like them
they still have a good team they're
still considered one of their favorites
in the west they're untrustworthy as
hell but they've got a good team that's
right they got a good team yeah they
have a good team uh are they much better
okay how about this
are they so much better with this move
if you look at it now the the slate is
wiped clean now let's reset it run it
back
nuggets versus clippers
who do you like
you know i mean like they they're a good
team but the nuggets are now we know the
nuggets are good we know the lakers pick
the nuggets ever so slightly but they
just grown for a reason dallas with the
superstar
first the warriors will be a big player
the warriors
and the warriors we talked about them
yesterday and the warriors too so
you you made some reference by the way
to this other team houston what what are
you trying to say about houston you got
some you got some thoughts on that oh
are you are you are you done on the
clippers you got it done
with them okay
exactly
they're not even worth spending that
much time on but but okay just just just
to put a ball on just to put a ball on
it you do like the higher okay like you
know we were we were both conflicted
about the doc firing there needed to be
a fall guy for all the failures not just
this year but in past years with live
city clippers and bomber thought that it
was doc and okay we all we got it we
know it hurt us but we got it but
looking at it at this right now right
here right now with that roster to me
hiring lou and chauncey billups i like
the move is it the right i'll say i like
it
mike i say i'll say i like the higher
but the higher doesn't match the message
that we got from steve ballmer unless
steve ballmer says don't believe
everything you hear and don't believe
everything you read i never said that so
all the reports are wrong you know i
just wanted to move on from doc rivers i
don't know
listen maybe this is a situation
everybody wins because doc doc ended up
with a five-year deal in philly i told
you i like that as well i like i like
that fit for him i like what he brings
to that franchise so he ends up with a
five-year deal in philly you know a
subject that we'll come back to a lot
today giving our our guests as well
michael sometimes things just run their
course
and even if it is somebody who was in
the locker room uh and an assistant on
the same team i do think ty lue has an
opportunity to step back and now
chauncey phillips as well to step back
with a 30 000 foot view of this
situation
and say okay what needs to be done
differently given how we underachieved
this past year what needs to be done
differently
i just destined never to see the
conference finals i it's the it's the
same but remixed so to speak i i can i
can see i'm optimistic i'm an eternal
optimist what can i say um
yeah exactly